Uh, it's time for our next game,
Worst Red Carpet Questions.
Worst Red Carpet
Questions.
(charactery voice): The 88th
Academy Awards are this weekend,
and they're super important.
-Uh, we're gonna...
-(laughter)
Everyone's very serious
at the 88th Academy Awards,
the most important thing going
on in the world this weekend.
Find out which white
will walk away
with a golden power trinket.
The 88th Academy Awards!
Very, very fancy. But before
Hollywood's hungriest enter
the theater, they first have
to deal with the red carpet--
which, for the record,
does not match the drapes--
where they will face
uncomfortable questions
in their uncomfortable
evening attire
from uncomfortable-looking
reporters.
But we can make the Oscars
more awkward,
so I would like you to give me
the worst red carpet questions
you can think of in 60 seconds.
And begin. Katy.
Who are you?
Yeah, points.
I-I get that a lot.
Points. Uh, Katie.
Has fame filled the void?
The answer to that is no.
Uh, Alison.
Will you give your agent
my script
for Paul Blart 3,
Fart Detective?
Oh, wait a minute!
-There's yet to... -Why wasn't
Paul Blart 2 Fart Detective?!
It was bound to be a trilogy!
-I would've watched that.
-We've all been waiting!
Points. Uh, Katie O'Brien.
Who's wearing you?
Yes, points. Points.
Alison Brie.
What's Macaulay Culkin
really like?
Yeah, points. Katie O'Brien.
Where does your dick fall
on a scale of Shia LaBeouf
-to Jon Hamm?
-Points.
-Ali. -Hey, uh,
are those things the same size?
Like, I'm thinkin' this one's
a little bigger than that one.
-What you think? You-you agree?
-Points.
-Katy. -Uh, what's your backup
plan if acting doesn't work out?
All right, points.
Katie O'Brien.
Do you have a date tonight
or will you die alone?
-All right, points.
-Um...
Like a bald man in a hospital,
staring at a sunset. Katy.
Has your face
always looked like that?
Yes, points. Perfect.